this tax filing deadline day President
Trump says Americans are winning because
of tax reform for more on that and where
we're headed next we turn to Texas
congressman Kevin Brady chairman of the
House Ways and Means Committee mr.
chairman thanks for being here Brett
thanks for having me you know you got
over the hump you got the tax law done
now it's tax day obviously it's a year
before you really see the changes your
thoughts at how this is shaping up and
you know the criticism that you all took
for getting this passed yes so I hate
tax day I think most families do they
hate tax week the good news is this is
the last time Americans will file their
taxes under that old complicated unfair
tax code going forward it'll not just be
simpler families will keep more of what
they earn Main Street businesses will
keep more of what they earn and we've
redesigned it so our US companies can
compete and where when anywhere in the
world especially here at home so we're
already seeing economic benefits from it
families now are already seeing higher
paychecks because they're tax
withholding has lowered so of
individuals stop and thank us for that
and again Main Street optimism is at a
30-year high all right and today you saw
speaker Ryan talking about fully
intending to make the tax cuts permanent
how is that possible yes so we made them
long-term for families and for small
businesses but because the Senate rules
weren't able to make them permanent we
think one of the provisions in phase 2
should be to make them permanent but
more than that we're really trying to
change the culture in Washington instead
of waiting 30 years and falling far
behind our competitors worldwide we
think we ought to move aggressively each
year to make America more competitive to
make businesses more productive to
encourage more innovation and we're
always looking for ways to make our tax
code more family-friendly
you know just helping families stretch
their budgets farther so our goal is
every year to make our tax code in our
country stronger all right stretching
budgets you have the CBO out with budget
deficit projections and you take a look
at the years 804 billion in 2018 and it
trickles up over a trillion dollars as
you
down to 20 28 1.5 trillion I'm gonna
play a sound bite from a guy you know
representative Kevin Brady excessive
federal spending czar disease
large federal budget deficits and
accumulating federal debt are symptoms
of this disease think if you cure our
spending disease the symptoms will
vanish you can treat the symptoms you
may temporarily alleviate some of the
pain but over time our economy will
continue to weaken our international
competitiveness will erode and our
children will become the first
generation American history this is poor
than the previous generation that was
2011 still true today it is the CBO
report not reported by very many is that
tax revenues in America actually grew
after tax reforms so it's the spending
that grew faster so my point is that we
don't have a revenue problem we have a
spending problem and that's where we
need to focus our efforts I'm convinced
we could start with the rescission
package of savings cuts that the
president's proposing working with
Congress secondly and I think this would
be I think a major signal to America the
house has already passed a bill last
year with the trillion dollars of
savings in the first reforms of an
entitlement Medicaid in its history it's
sitting in the Senate today
just a couple votes short we're gonna
encourage the Senate to move on that
bill because we think that takes a
significant step forward
speaking of the Senate Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell was on with Neil
Cavuto talking about that rescission
effort earlier the president meanwhile
was looking at this 1.3 trillion dollar
spending measure wants to rescind a lot
of that spending are you okay with well
he agreed to it you know he was involved
in a negotiation and signed the bill but
he warned I'm never going to do this
again yeah but we had an agreement with
the Democrats and I don't think he was
surprised by what he said when he came
out and can't make an agreement one
month and say okay we really didn't mean
it and come back the next month and say
oh we really didn't mean our agreement I
mean that doesn't sound very promising
about Raziel rescission possibilities
look before recent history decisions
were pretty common they happened many
years Congress didn't take all of
what presents proposed but they took
some of them and I can't think of a more
important time for that to happen
especially today for example Congress is
moving forward with the first redesign
on the IRS in two decades redesigning it
we're focusing it on customer service
and reining in the abuses of it you know
we ought to be looking at tax savings
and excuse me on spending savings I
think every day do you think anything
else big legislatively it's going to
happen before the midterms so I think
the redesign and reining in the IRS is
one that could we go to the President's
desk I think it's important for us now
that we're armed with one of the best
tax codes on the planet
we need more customers so I think a new
modern Africa NAFTA by the end of the
year I think is critically important the
economy and I think we ought to move on
workforce look there's only two things
holding us back now that we have the new
tax code need new customers we need more
workers and that's where we think there
are a lot of Americans who are trapped
on the sidelines in our welfare system
we shouldn't give up on them and frankly
the country needs them less I think we
can make progress there last thing as
you look to the midterms you're now at
42 Republicans who are either not
running retiring charlie dents getting
out of office before he was going to
finish up his term the Speaker the house
is not running again that's an uphill
battle for holding on to the house it is
an uphill battle it is historically and
is this time but people don't vote in
April they vote in November and a lot
can happen between now and then and I
think again back home I just see a new
optimism on Main Street I see it among
our workers and now we're seeing jobs
coming back the United States and giving
this new hope America is back because
this tax reform and so the other day I
think voters gonna choose did they want
to go back to this tax code they filed
with today with taking more of what they
earn or do they want a new feature for
the country mr. chairman on this tax day
we appreciate your time thank you breath